for U.S House speaker Nancy Pelosi a
high-profile trip to Taiwan fraught with
both complications and contradictions
America's third most powerful politician
repeating Washington's commitment to
protect democracy on the self-governed
island while also respecting beijing's
so-called One China policy
today the world faces a choice between
democracy and autocracy America's
determination to preserve democracy here
in Taiwan and around the world remains
Ironclad
Taiwanese president Tsai ingwin who gave
Pelosi one of the highest civilian
honors promised to defend the island
from beijing's threats
aggression against Democratic Taiwan
would have a tremendous impact on the
security of the entire indo-pacific
facing deliberately heightened military
threats Taiwan will not back down we
will firmly uphold our nation's
sovereignty and continue to hold the
line of defense for democracy
China which considers Taiwan a part of
its territory has said it once a
peaceful reunification and Views
Pelosi's visit as a direct provocation
Taiwan saying when and her ilk are
clinging to the U.S and turning their
backs on National Justice these
behaviors that go against the trend of
times will not change the international
consensus of one China and will not
change the historic Trend that Taiwan
will inevitably return to the motherland
those who play with fire will not come
to a good end and those who offend China
will be punished
even during Pelosi's visit China's
reaction was fast and furious suspending
imports and exports of several Goods to
and from Taiwan conducting joint air and
sea live ammunition drills near Taiwan
and summoning the U.S ambassador in
Beijing
Pelosi's trip has come to an end but
with chinese-american relations at such
a low point it's not clear yet what the
long-term repercussions of this visit
will be
Divya kapalan is the international
editor of Taiwan plus she joins us now
live via Skype from Taipei Debbie we've
just heard about how unhappy China is
it's carrying out Military drills what
are the people of Taiwan making of all
of this
so the people of Taiwan are used to
China's aggressive language and
posturing but what is uh concerning them
at the moment is one of those economic
actions that that China has taken
against Taiwan Banning a number of
products particularly Agricultural and
food products although China was quite
careful not to ban the products that
China does actually need the two sides
have very robust trade with uh China
being taiwan's largest trading partner
but at the same time China needs
taiwan's for its Supply chains for
electronic goods and semiconductors so
there are businesses or smaller
businesses here that will be affected on
the other hand there is also the Specter
of China imposing its military might on
Taiwan and China's made that very clear
by releasing a map of its plans of these
large-scale drills that it's planning to
do from August 4th to the 7th and this
map show shows these live fire drills
that are due to take place that even
flybys possibly into taiwan's airspace
which is unprecedented that will be
taking place during those days and that
map has also shown that China's drills
will come very close and impede on
taiwan's territorial Waters coming close
to Taiwan soil uh just about 16
kilometers away so people here in Taiwan
are watching it very closely and trying
to make a sense of Nazi Pelosi's visit
on the one hand it's given Taiwan
legitimacy and Taiwan people have seen
this as support from the US but on the
other hand while it's huge on symbolism
they also feel that perhaps there could
have been more substance to it that's
our old friend and colleague Divya
gopalan now the international editor of
Taiwan plus live in Taipei Divya good to
see you many thanks
Patrick Fork is a journalist based in
Beijing he says that China doesn't want
to appear weak in the face of Pelosi's
visit
well there was more fiery rhetoric from
the foreign Ministry in Beijing today
spokesperson watching Ying saying that
when the one China principle is being
undermined then there will be fierce
storms and thunderclouds in the Taiwan
Strait She also addressed criticism over
this increased military activity around
Taiwan saying that China had made itself
clear to the US but when the U.S does
not listen it needs to use ways to make
it listen that China's acting in
self-defense you know part of the reason
why all of this is happening is because
the U.S or members of Congress at least
including the house Speaker don't want
to be backing down to Chinese aggression
and Nancy Pelosi today she said that
this visit was about deepening the
friendship between Washington and Taiwan
but also importantly to show that
America stands with Taiwan in the face
of increased assertiveness from a
amazing ironically there are concerns
some people will say that this could
lead to further military aggression and
more regular military aggression from
China against Taiwan and we have seen a
little bit of that already since her
arrival in Taipei the big question is
whether this will continue and how long
for
koloshitako was taiwan's presidential
spokeswoman she says the Taiwanese are
undeterred by the consequences of
Pelosi's visit
president Thai was elected by Taiwanese
people with more than 80 million votes
it is the result of a democracy everyone
can see how China is being unreasonable
Roc Taiwan is a Southern and independent
country it has never been ruled by CCP
and is not part of China
China must recognize this so as not to
live in in its own fantasy Taiwan is not
a part of Mr she's a Chinese dream so
they do have to wake up Taiwanese people
don't agree what China said I have been
asked what do you think are you nervous
are you scared
but uh because China's reaction is not
new to us uh of course we are cautious
because this time they are more
aggressive than they were in 1996 when
we had our first Democratic presidential
election our military has been cared for
to deal with it at the military airports
across the country starting from
yesterday afternoon fighter plans have
taken off and landed one after another
and we have uh conducted drills too
but the point is we do not seek war but
we will prepare for the worst
I think they have to respect our rights
of uh determination
self-determination China has attacked on
us has already begun it's not new
military threats economic sanctions
cyber attacks are all happening right
now so this is uh just making clear for
Taiwanese that we must continue to
diversify economically and politically
and keep a distance from China that's
the big lesson we have